eric ciotti député les républicains des
alpes-maritimes est l'invité d'auditions
publiques bonsoir soi et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires de public sénat de lcp
assemblée nationale de la fp du figaro
pour être donc avec nous alors que se
tient toujours bien sûr le bureau
politique de l heure consacrée à votre
débâcle aux européennes d'ailleurs vous
en venez vous allez pouvoir nous faire
part des premières déclarations avec moi
tout de suite sur ce plateau paul briat
de la fpf vincent roux du figaro et du
figaro live messieurs bonsoir un
semblant soir paul et puis brigitte
boucher au riad mancini nous rejoindrons
tout à l'heure et deux parlementaires en
feront leur entrée sur ce plateau dans
une vingtaine de minutes pour dialoguer
vous interpellez eric ciotti il s'agit
de rachid thema le sénateur socialiste
du val d'oise et de ludovic mendes
député la république en marche de
moselle est ce que pour être avec nous
un risque d'otite vous avez quitté avant
l'heure la nuit des longs couteaux
j'espère que ça ne sera pas la nuit des
longs couteaux parce que au lendemain de
la défaite
vous avez utilisé le mot de débattre
mais c'est vrai que la défaite est
lourde qu'elle est sévère pour nous nous
avons besoin d'unité nous avons besoin
de rassemblement c'est une défaite
collective qui nous touche tous chacun a
sa part de responsabilité cela a été dit
par laurent wauquiez par françois-xavier
bellamy et j'espère que face à cette
situation il y aura une exigence il faut
qu'il y ait un devoir de responsabilité
au sein de notre famille politique parce
que aller dans le jeu des petites
phrases
des petites querelles dans son coeur
d'ailleurs deux tranches serait
suicidaire parce que ce qui est en jeu
c'est la survie de la droite république
on vote - année là aujourd'hui c'est la
survie de la droite républicaine et moi
je pense que dans notre pays on a besoin
d'une droite républicaine qui incarne
une alternative crédible responsable
exigeante à la fois en marche et à la
fois au rassemblement de vue
effectivement ce qui est en jeu c'est
éventuellement notre disparition mais
vous nous confirmez d'abord que donc
vous l'avez dit françois xavier
beltchika nation aussi de la
détermination encore à deux pattes
existe à combattre de renaître à nous
remettre en cause d'accords refonder on
va attendre les lichens
on va en parler vers ces objectifs de
reconquête laurendeau qui a déjà fait
une première proposition mais vous étiez
effectivement tout à l'heure il ya
quelques minutes encore dans ce bureau
politique et vous nous confirmer que
françois-xavier bellamy votre candidat
malheureux donc à demander pardon
il a exprimé avec beaucoup de dignité
comme il a conduit sa campagne ses
regrets et c'est vrai qu'ils considèrent
et il l'a souvent dit pendant la
campagne qu'il portait une
responsabilité et il a le sentiment
qu'un peu individuellement il ya une
responsabilité personnelle je l'exonère
très volontiers de ce sentiment je pense
que la responsabilité est collective
jeudi à meaux signe à ces difficultés ce
moment où vous les avez cités vous des
consciences il y à ces difficultés s'il
ya eu ces difficultés
elles puisent leur source dans la double
défaite de 2017 et dans notre difficulté
à nous reconstruire face à aussi au
machiavélisme d' emmanuel macron qui a
tout fait pour installer ce débat ce duo
paul finalement entre le rassemblement
national et lui on va peut-être venir
justement sur ce duo paul avec mâcon
mais avant il ya une question je voulais
vous poser eric ciotti sur les personnes
qui sont là et les personnes qui ne sont
pas là ce soir au bureau politique ni
gérard larcher ni bruno retailleau ne
sont là est ce que vous craignez des
manoeuvres est ce que vous craignez une
tentative de putsch contre laurent
wauquiez écoutez
je ne l'espère pas en tout cas je crois
que ce soir valérie pécresse était là
jean françois copé était là moi je forme
le voeu qu'on se réunisse qu'on se
rassemble déjà vous ne rassemblez
londres en débatte
bien sûr c'est un enjeu difficile et si
on a ses difficultés c'est aussi parce
que préalablement des personnalités sont
allés en marche nous ont quittés ont
joué le jeu aussi de nos adversaires
donc il y à l'exigence aujourd'hui dans
ce moment extrêmement difficile que
chacun est un esprit de responsabilité
parce que ma question
j'entends ne craignez vous espérer qu'il
n'y ait pas de manoeuvre qu'il ait pas
de push mais ce que vous craignez que ce
soit manoeuvre qui soit en cours il peut
toujours y avoir une inquiétude dans
cette période de qui et où chacun est un
peu où l'émotion est forte ou le choc de
la défaite et est brutale bien sûr qu'il
faut prendre garde à ce qu'il y ait
concombre regarde tous dans la même
direction qu'il y ait pas d des
tentatives individuelles c'est le voeu
que je forme s j'espère qu'il sera
exaucé avec ce qui est ce que ce sont
des tentatives individuelles quand par
exemple ou city valérie pécresse elle
dit que la ligne politique est venu jean
françois copé lui va encore plus loin
dit
la situation est intenable il parle d'un
partie verrouillée et puis comme vous
bruno retailleau ce matin disait le
risque c'est la disparition
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ces tirs
croisés c'est pas des forcément des tirs
croisés
laurent wauquiez lui même a indiqué
qu'il fallait changer beaucoup de choses
je crois que même qu'il a utilisé le mot
il faut il faut tout changer
l'une pour changer écoutez il est il est
élu par les militants très très
largement il ya des instances ses
instances lui lui témoignent leur
confiance je crois qu encore une fois
c'est pas une responsabilité
individuelle
qui peut prétendre aujourd'hui dans les
voies d'abonnement des il n'a pas
demandé pardon lui
peut prétendre dans les vois que vous
avez cités qui se sont exprimés qu'il
aurait fait mieux
aujourd'hui voilà fricoter pardon et
compte les avis ils vont tu veux partir
je ne reviendrai pas oui mais moi je
n'irai pas sur ce terrain j'invite mes
amis à ne pas y aller non plus voilà
parce que la difficulté
elle est née du fait que pour la
première fois depuis le début de la vème
république on n'a pas été présent au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
on a eu derrière une élection
législative ou monsieur macron a nommé à
débaucher dans nos rangs des ministres
ce qui a créé un trouble majeur et qui
n'est toujours pas résorbé dans notre
électorat et puis dimanche il y a eu
cette alternative où finalement ceux qui
voulaient voter contre emmanuel macron
ont préféré choisir
marine le pen est ce qu'ils voulaient
faire barrage à marine le pen ont
préféré voter pour la liste de monsieur
macron donc on s'est retrouvés un peu
aneto au milieu victimes de ce vote
utile que tactiquement stratégiquement
on pourrait dire cyniquement emmanuel
macron à installer mais il a installé ce
débat je dis que c'est
extraordinairement dangereux c'est un
jeu politique
c'est un jeu politicien parce que demain
si on va dans cette logique il n'y aura
plus d'autre alternative aux français
que le choix à nouveau entre marine le
pen et lui si l'élection avait lieu
dimanche
monsieur macron serait sans doute
considérer son assurance vie
c'est son assurance vie politique c'est
une formule que j'utilise fréquemment le
froid le rassemblement national et
l'assurance vie politique d' emmanuel
macron mais demain un jour ça peut
changer
aller dans cette voie c'est
extraordinairement dangereux d'affaiblir
les partis républicains apparemment
c'est quand même ce que ont plébiscité
les lecteurs les électeurs hier dans
cette configuration voulait dénoncer
laurent wauquiez l'a dénoncé mais on
mange donc je la dénonce pas je la
constate il ya eu cet effet vote utile
et on a entendu donc laurent wauquiez
s'est exprimée donc ce soir
il demande qu'on mette tout sur la table
et des états généraux avaient une âme à
la rentrée mais on en a pas tellement de
d'autocritique on entend le pardon de
françois-xavier bellamy on n'entend pas
d'auto critique de la part de laurent
wauquiez
il a assumé ses responsabilités je les
écoutais pour partie puisque je suis
avec vous 7h et le bureau politique se
bouffe aidante jeu les jo les écouter il
a exprimé bien sûr nous avons tous une
part de responsabilité moi le premier
nous assumons laquelle notre les autres
qui défendent est par exemple une ligne
j'ai envie de dire de défense
identitaire vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que j'avance prix est ce que là vous
faites votre mea culpa sur cette ligne
là alors qu'on a par ailleurs reproché
par exemple à françois-xavier bellamy de
défendre des positions trop peu
archaïque rigide sur certains sujets de
société c'est votre part damien abad
excusez moi qui ai piqué députés qui dit
que je converse contre conservatisme
sociétal des questions identitaires
sonne ne nous permettrons jamais de
gagner
l'ex résidence d'ailleurs considéré que
ses prises de position comptables
d'erreur je suis d'accord avec damien
abad ascendant damien abad dans son
analyse
on peut pas avoir qu'un positionnement
voilà moi je défends
l'autorité de la république je défends
la protection des français
je combats le communautarisme islamistes
je suis pour le maintien d'une certaine
identité française et j'en suis fier je
ne pense pas que ce soit une erreur
ces valeurs il faut les défendre parce
qu'elles sont au coeur des
préoccupations des français et je
déforme la régulation très forte des
flux migratoires
parce que l'immigration telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
l'arrivée très nombreuses au cours des
dernières années voir des dernières
décennies d'immigrés dont on n'a pas su
auxquelles on n'a pas su transmettre les
valeurs de la république auquel on on
n'a pas su donner les moyens de
s'intégrer à la république ont conduit
au communautarisme et a beaucoup de
menaces qui pèsent sur notre société
donc naturellement ce n'est pas mon
habitude quand il ya une difficulté de
changer de convictions je les assume ce
que je sois écologie leurs proches de
celles des républicains au sens large
mais particulièrement également du
rassemblement national
je les mets en avant j'ai toujours eu
ces convictions je les ai toujours
défendu et je crois qu'elles sont au
coeur de ce qui est la droite
républicaine
après nous devons avoir sur une
multitude de sujets un discours un
programme qui parle à plus d'électeurs
on a aujourd'hui c'est incontestable une
défiance c'est les jeunes c'est pas
normal un parti précisé % de bien seuls
80 soit aussi un avenir doit parler à
toutes les catégories sociales doit
parler à toutes les classes d'âge
donc il y à cette nécessité de s'élargir
je dirais pas de s'élargir politiquement
parce que s'élargir politiquement c'est
quelque part se dénaturer et moi je suis
pour une ligne claire et droite c'est
pas parce qu'on a eu c'est évidemment
qu'elles droit s'est adressé à plus de
catégories et de façon différente ce que
c'est ça qui a manqué dans votre
campagne
une ligne claire et droite pas si si je
veut relativiser je rappelle aussi la
relation difficile entre l'élection
européenne et la droite républicaine
voilà dans notre famille rappelez-vous
en même temps problèmes de confinement
rappeler même de mahler rappelez-vous
pasqua seguin et chirales franc on a
toujours eu dans notre
famille politique à la fois un courant
plus souverainiste est un courant plus
européen l'offre donc elle peut être
troublée elle peut être troublé
alors que de l'autre côté vous aviez
emmanuel macron je parle même pas de
madame oiseaux qui a été effacé de la
fiche mais emmanuel macron qui a porté
un message d'une europe très fédéral
dont pro-européenne vous aviez de madame
le pen qui portait un message
d'hostilité à l'europe nous nous étions
pour une europe raisonnables
responsables qui se heureusement n'a pas
été poussé la semaine
c'était la seule ligne possible mais
elle était plus difficile à expliquer à
l'épousé est la seule d'une possible et
simplement un espèce de fourre tout oui
je crois que sortir de l'europe quelque
part comme le propose madame le pen dans
sa logique serait extraordinaire parce
que je remet elle dit plus haut oui mais
enfin c'est quand même ce qu'il y a
derrière et ce que nourrissent les
parties avec lesquelles elles et alliées
en europe et le fédéralisme quelque part
qui est la logique
et cette ouverture des frontières des
marchés que propose aussi monsieur
macron me paraît tout aussi dangereuses
dont on n'évolue pas dans le discours
sur l'europe
même dans le cadre des états généraux
comme moi je ne suis pas pour la sortie
de l'europe et je vois pas pourquoi j'ai
voulu re election enfin si vous voulez
je suis pas vous voulez vous être
je suis pas pour l'europe fédérale vous
voulez c'est le bouquet non je suis fort
possible que électorale en dressant sur
quels éléments programmatiques vous êtes
prêt je vous dis que on a pas dans ce
débat un peu réducteur et un peu binaire
qui fait qu emmanuel macron et marine le
pen dans un jeu qui leur conviennent
tous les deux ont volontairement
raisonnement peugeot n'a pas chez lui on
n'a pas su convaincre y passe y avait là
aussi un message très clair c'était le
message de l'écologie qu'est ce que vous
avez ce que vous dites on aurait dû
parler davantage d'écologie par exemple
laurent wauquiez a sans doute sans doute
sans doute parce que c'est un message
vers oui c'est un message qui préoccupe
beaucoup les jeunes gens personnellement
j'avais parlé avec ma fille qui était
très sensible assez assez assez question
donc c'est un sujet qui préoccupe tous
les français bien sûr mais qui préoccupe
et ils ont raison peut-être encore un
peu plus
les jeunes eric ciotti dans le
communiqué qu'il a fait laurent wauquiez
ce soir dit qu'il va falloir remettre
tout à plat et notamment la stratégie
d'alliance quand on regarde les
résultats d'hier soir on voit qu'aucun
parti de droite aujourd'hui ne peut
gagner seul
alors qu'est ce que va être la stratégie
qu'est ce que doit être selon vous la
stratégie pour les républicains
continuer vers le centre ou bien suivre
l'exemple de thierry mariani de jean
paul garraud peut-être des alliances
avec le rassemblement national n'ont
aucune alliance avec le rassemblement
national
nous l'avons dit c'est clair et c'est
sans ambiguïté pour les verts le sens et
sans ambiguïté il faut sans doute que
les sensibilités qui s'organisait autour
du centre qu'incarner dans une histoire
un peu plus lointaine l'udf et les
sensibilités plus gaulliste qu'incarner
le rpr se retrouver sur ses clubs et sur
l'impopulaire se retrouvera dans ce
genre de stratégie il électorat qui a
apparemment complètement disparu de nos
écrans radar il se retrouvera dans une
stratégie qui puise dans le gaullisme
dans le gaullisme qui puise dans ce
qu'elle prenne ce tract du centre ce
qu'était le rpr louis mais c'est pour ça
qu'on a la nécessité d'avoir une
alliance parce que si on pense tous la
même chose on ne pense plus rien donc
moi je propose qu'il y ait une famille
avec des idées très claires et puis on a
nourri une alliance dans cette élection
européenne avec les c'est ce que ça vous
a pas nui à mon sens le risque quand
même de la guerre fait justement
écoutez moi je ne le crois pas mais il
faut là où je vous rejoins il faut des
idées très claires très très identifiée
quitte à ce qu'elles soient portées par
des personnes différentes et qu'à un
moment on se retrouve
il n'y a pas que l'électorat populaire
qui vous a manqué en fait vous avez
aussi si on regarde la carte d'hier soir
vous n'avez plus de maillage territorial
la seule préfecture métropolitaine dans
laquelle est arrivée en tête la liste de
monsieur dany c'est le puy-en-velay
c'est-à-dire demeurant wauquiez grand
bien lui fasse
et c'est la plus grande ville de france
et c'est une big de quelques dizaines de
milliers d'habitants vous aviez pourtant
dit que vous aviez reconquérir le
pouvoir avec ce maillage territorial
il a disparu
vous allez faire là je crois que vous
tirez quand même des conclusions très
très hâtive très hâtive le maillage
territorial avec des élus locaux il
s'exprime lors des élections locales
l'élection européenne c'est une élection
qui apparaît plus lointaines autrefois
avec des bastions où la participation
la participation est plus faible donc je
suis convaincu que beaucoup d'électeurs
qui ont eu ce réflexe du vote utile
choisiront lors des élections
municipales lors des élections
cantonales lors des élections régionales
les élus républicains qu'ils connaissent
et qu'ils apprécient et je crois que le
scénario sera très différent pour en
marche la qui lui n'a aucune
implantation territoriale en termes
d'élus alors je ne conteste pas qu'il ya
une sur le territoire il ya eu des
résultats surtout dans les villes
d'ailleurs très favorable plus favorable
en marche mais là dessus
rendez vous dans quelques mois et je
fais le pari c'est un enjeu pour nous
parce que c'est un objectif nous devons
viser aujourd'hui un redressement
spectaculaire et je crois qu'il est
possible j'en suis même convaincu pour
les élections municipales
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que
justement notamment dans votre
département
votre formation elle-même aux prochaines
élections municipales et notamment à
nice où donc on va t la mairie vous
risquez d'avoir de mauvaises surprises
sachant que c'est le rassemblement
national qui est arrivé largement en
tête devant la république en marche il
devant les écologistes vous n'arriver
qu'en quatrième position
je ne le crois pas je crois que les
scrutins sont totalement différents qui
a un lien direct que les élus que nous
sommes dans les alpes-maritimes mais
peut parler du maire de cannes david
lisnard du maire d'antibes jean leonetti
du maire de grasse gérant bio ils ont un
lien très fort avec leur territoire
qu'ils ont beaucoup de résultats et je
suis persuadé qu'à nice aussi les choses
se régleront
dans notre famille pendant que vous êtes
heureux sera plus longuement tout à
l'heure sur vos propres ambitions
municipales à nice à ce sera dans la
troisième partie de l'émission encore
une question avant de conclure monsieur
cette première partie j'avais envie de
vous demander eric ciotti est ce que
vous êtes en vieux du triomphe de matteo
salvini en italie non je suis pas
envieux par par nature en vieux que
notre famille politique retrouve
retrouve sa place parce que sa place
c'est une bonne place pour le pays aussi
parce qu'aujourd'hui on l'oublié un peu
dans cette élection
mais le pays souffre beaucoup et les
solutions et de monsieur macro et de
madame le pen ne sont pas bonnes pour le
pays donc ce sont les électeurs qui sont
trompés ce que vous dites finalement je
ne dis jamais que les électeurs se sont
trompés on peut tromper les électeurs
c'est la droite républicaine et de
sifflet la 13e
il s'est passé en 2010 est moi je
n'accuserai jamais les électeurs c'est
la démocratie et les lecteurs par
définition je respecte son choix
et tous les choix j'ai dû bien de tous
les choix en démocratie sont
respectables
après jeudi qu' il y a des leaders qui
induisent les électeurs en france unie
dernière laurent wauquiez ce qui peut
rester à la tête des républicains avec 8
% aux européennes
je le crois qu'ils souhaitaient et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour le
grand débat que en tout cas les états
généraux que laurent wauquiez
va compte lancer à partir de septembre
j'attends de ces débats des propositions
fortes je crois qu'on se redressera
aussi voilà on le disait tout à l'heure
on a manqué peut-être de clarté sur le
projet européen mais c'était complexe il
faut des idées claires il faut des idées
précises chiffrées une la baisse de la
fiscalité de façon massive d'au moins
10% sur l'impôt sur le revenu il faut
qu'on appuie sur ses idées sur ses
objectifs des idées sur la sécurité sur
l'immigration défendrait un texte de loi
à l'assemblée nationale le 20 juin sur
les questions de sécurité
j'y travaille et cet après midi voyait
donc sonné tout de suite au travail avec
les syndicats de police c'est ça l'enjeu
de la reconstruction
merci messieurs tout de suite la
deuxième partie d'auditions publiques
avec les deux parlementaires que je vous
ai annoncé qu'ils font leur entrée sur
ce plateau
[Musique]
voilà pendant qu'il s'installe une
question d'un internaute du figaro là
est ce qu'il vous demande eric ciotti ce
que les républicains ne se sont pas
trompés de chefs exclure alain juppé
lors de la dernière présidentielle a été
une erreur
le regrettez vous on en parlait à
l'instant par définition vous ne le
faisiez remarquer les électeurs ne se
trompe a donc voilà le choix était
massif important alain juppé n'a pas su
convaincre
voilà ludovic mendes et avec nos bonsoir
vous êtes sûr député la république en
marche de moselle à vos côtés et rachid
taha le sénateur socialiste du val
d'oise peut-être que vous vous sentez en
peut-être en harmonie peut-être voir en
solidarité avec le représentant d'un
parti qui a mordu la poussière également
non non pas du tout non pas du tout non
parce que c'est pas comme ça qu'on vit
la vie politique ou ne s'inscrit pas
dans un parti on ne fait pas on se
présente pas des élections en disant
qu'elle sort j'espère la question c'est
ce que ce que nous portons peut avoir du
sens et je pense que c'est là dessus
nous n'avons pas le même projet et je
crois que le début de l'émission l'a
encore démontré
je pense que c'est sain pour la
démocratie donc n'y a pas de solidarité
à avoir et moi je souhaite plutôt des
partis on va dire le maintien du clivage
droite gauche mais c'est pas l'intention
c'est pas le maintien parce que nous
sommes fétichiste du maintien c'est que
dans une démocratie il faut une
alternative une alternance c'est le
principe démocratie aujourd'hui il est
vrai qu'elle mène maquereau a réussi un
coup de génie en 2007 aujourd'hui de
dire que la seule alternative à -
emmanuel kron et toi le front national
donc il sait qui bloque le jeu je crois
que c'est pas c'est dangereux pour notre
démocratie
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vu que
celui qui peut battre le maquereau
naveau approuvé l'exigent a été aidé par
une autre invitée non il n'a pas dit
tout à fait la même chose il a dit qu'
il était tombé dans un piège moi je ne
parle pas de piège de maquereaux donc
c'est de la différence je crois que nous
avons mais là n'est pas l'essentiel je
pense qu'on a d'autres sujets de
différence d'ailleurs aussi avec mon
collègue à ma droite la plus conne
marche comme avec effectivement l'air
plus qu'un rappel la politique là là on
se rejoint je crois que les convictions
sont importants dans démocratie et que
président de la république sa majorité
aujourd'hui expriment globalement une
absence de conviction ont même rejeté le
fait que la france puisse avoir des
racines une culture française
on sait pas trop où se situer en marche
le en même temps qu'ils symbolisent
finalement ce pouvoir c'est le mot clé
c'est la clé de voûte de la nouvelle
majorité leur même temps c'est tout et
son contraire
et au final c'est une forme
d'immobilisme est-ce que depuis deux ans
la france a progressé sur les grands
sujets est-ce que son économie se porte
mieux est ce que le chômage a autant
régresser en france que partout en
europe
est ce que la croissance est aussi forte
en france qu'en europe parce que nos
dépenses publiques ont diminué ce que
nos déficits brokers on ne laisse que la
dette a diminué ses notes sur ces
questions on voit bien que cette absence
de projet clair de courage politique
aboutit à une forme d'immobilisme et que
la survie vous disiez tout à l'heure et
l'assurance vie politique c'est dire
simplement oui je fais pas grand chose
mais je reste là parce qu'autrement ça
serait madame le pen
voilà c'est ça le seul message et ça
c'est dangereux pour l'affranchir
collègue monsieur ce pti c'est
intéressant ce que payet d'immobilisme
et je crois que les français ne l'ont
pas vu comme ça hier parce qu'on porte
un vrai projet européen donc ce n'est
pas l'immobilisme on s'est battu sur sur
un vrai projet européen d'ailleurs
malgré les 1 % d'écart qui nous nous
éloignons du rassemblement national qui
est juste devant nous on fait autant de
sièges et à la fin c'est à dire 23
eurodéputés donc on peut pas parler d'
immobilisme
on a fait une campagne vous avez fait la
vôtre les verts ont fait la leur
d'ailleurs je crois que personne même
les sondeurs n'ont pas prévu que la
liste europe écologie en attendant la
liste europe écologie le bilan je crois
que souvenez-vous messe du temps nicolas
sarkozy vous disais vous même sur tous
les plateaux télé attendait la fin du
quinquennat
attendons la fin du cac et là en tout
cas aujourd'hui on est la cinquième
place et il est mal parcours on est le
pays où on est à la cinquième place sur
les investissements mondiaux car sur le
territoire le chômage est redescendu au
plus bas depuis 2009 alors certes devant
le tendre avec la moyenne tant que pays
européens mais au moins ça que ça
fonctionne ça prouve que ça fonctionne
et ça ça avance
il malgré tout alors moi je le dis on a
fait une petite
électorale mais ce n'est pas une défaite
politique au contraire on revêt des
nouvelles de nouvelles ont gravi de
nouvelles marches entre guillemets on
pourrait presque sentir une humidité une
humiliation électorales de votre côté ce
que finira à vue pour cent c'est quand
même très dur et ça prouve que votre
ligne identitaire depuis des années un
peu nationaliste libéral qui l inverse
en fait du nationalisme social porté par
marine le pen
cette course effrénée depuis 2004 avec
le front national sur ses thèses
l'immigration l'islam de france
l'identité nationale a été un marchepied
vous avez en fait ouvert un boulevard au
rassemblement national et aujourd'hui
vous ai dit on va mettre quelqu'un aussi
de très identitaire certainement très
catholique sens commun étaient très
présents et vous avez perdu comment vous
l'analysez c'est en fait je crois que
c'est je crois que c'est une vraie
caricature c'est là non c'est la fiction
que vous avez décrite le fond ça prouve
que vous êtes sur la même vie c'est le
fantasme que nourrit monsieur macron et
peut-être conduit à son isolement en
europe parce que demain il sera donc
totalement isolé l'a31 soir le monde au
calme à isoler en europe la réalité elle
est là et il n'aura pas la capacité de
peser
moi j'assume mes convictions et je
continuerai à les défendre parce que je
suis convaincu qu elles sont bonnes pour
le pays
vous prenez une forme de deux sociétés
très communautariste
j'y suis j'y suis veut pas dire si le
communautarisme conduit à la montée de
deux fléaux qui se traduisent par des
menaces fortes contre notre société
rien n'a été fait pour les terroristes
ne fait rien n'a été fait pour les
combattre
la séparation a été fait je parle des
éléments pour lutter pour redéfinir
notre laïcité à la française contre le
communautarisme la loi la loi contre le
chêne le terrorisme ce n'est pas une loi
contre le terrorisme
c'était la sortie de l'état d'urgence
c'est un dispositif qui nous a plutôt
affaibli
donc ces questions la question de
l'augmentation record de l'immigration
puisque le nom vous le savez vous avez
les mêmes données que moi non c'est pas
200 milles dans 155 mille titres de
séjour mais notre secret de ce jour vous
le savez c'est très ouvert pour des
étudiants pour des personnes qui veulent
travailler temporairement
c'est un arbre ou les horaires peur
comme le rassemblement national on est
submergé tout ça est faux mais suis je
si vous lisez la réalité il faut que
vous assumez de dire que vous allez le
jura ce monde que l'assemblée l'a su sur
ces propos là j'assume nos différences
moi je de temps que je ne dois pas vous
le dire les mêmes propos je ne me réfère
jamais au rassemblement national je vais
vraiment les mêmes convictions
depuis de très longues années si on nous
avait écoutés sur ces sujets je crois
qu'on serait pas soumis à ces menaces
aujourd'hui alors moi je vous reconnais
monsieur ciotti effectivement vous avez
des positions et depuis très longtemps
là dessus je mange l'enjeu elles sont
constantes mais il faut constater que
nous n'avons pas les mêmes d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas les mêmes
effectivement c'est la plus haut marche
parce que je crois que entre la ligne
que vous porter volontaire et d'autres
comme ça et je dis pas que c'est votre
cas et certains chez vous il ya moi je
penses tu appliques au milieu parce que
monsieur ciotti
le problème que vous avez c'est que
depuis maintenant trop bon nous années
et tout à l'heure encore sur le plateau
vous avez utilisé les mots qui font peur
immigration identité racines et je crois
que votre souci le premier sous ses
racines à limbé dans le sens où vous
l'évoquez ce soutien scolaire à je vais
expliquer tout simplement ce qu'ils ne
font pas peur et je vous dis avant
différence c'est qu'en fait vous écrivez
mais comme d'autres une histoire de
france
une histoire qui n'est pas la véritable
histoire de france parce que ce que vous
vendez
c'est une histoire qui n'a jamais existé
la france c'est un vieux pays qui s'est
construit par sa géographie et par les
hommes et les femmes qui l'ont composé
et le c'est ce qui fait le sacrifice de
beaucoup d'entre eux c'est ce qui fait
effectivement cette belle nation quand
même
sommes nous les le roman française sauf
que vous en exclu et certains noms c'est
ça aussi mais si monsieur ciotti
par exemple vous savez bien que quand la
france est construit je crois qu'une
ville que vous connaissez bien tout ce
qui les unit c'est arrivé après d'autres
endroits
le côté nous sommes tous de cette une
culture etc ne s'est pas construit comme
ça la france c'est des gens qui sont
venus et qui enrichissent la culture
française notre histoire et quand vous
leur balancer la tête qui à ceux qui
auraient de bonnes racines versus pas
les autres il y aurait une identité
versus pas l'autre je crois que vous
cliver et le problème c'est que d'une
part au non français et je crois que ça
crée ce climat là est sacré ce danger là
au lieu de rassembler on exclut d'ores
et déjà des personnes ça c'est le
premier point est le deuxième point vous
faites de fait la courte échelle à
madame parce que je venais d'un mois
c'est ce que madame le pen en fait elle
se nourrit de ce débat là elle va
beaucoup plus loin que vous parce
qu'elle n'en tire des conséquences
vous vous arrêtez un certain stade je
vous le reconnaît elle va plus loin elle
veut exclure des gens de ce pays les
gens qui sont sous payés moi je prends
un exemple vous l'avez dit on vient
roh je dire dans quelques jours on
fêtera la libération de la france mais
qui à kia qui a libéré la provence quels
étaient les hommes les hommes qui ont
combattu qui sont morts sur la terre de
provence pour libérer la france est bien
sûr voyage sauf que leurs enfants leurs
enfants sont français ils sont en france
et de l'or et c'est là où vous avez un
souci c'est que très vite les rejoindre
sur ce modèle républicain
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que cette
histoire elle soit transmise à ceux qui
viennent en france aujourd'hui parce que
le modèle où on importerait une culture
extérieure qui devrait on parler moi je
vous parle pas dans ma moi je suis
c'est justement ce qui ce qui nous
distingue c'est que je considère qu'il
n'ya qu'une communauté c'est la
communauté nationale qui lie à une
république il ya une culture française
qui s'est enrichie enrichi au fil de
l'histoire d'abord successifs qui ont
fait ce moule républicain mais
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui refusent
aujourd'hui de s'intégrer à ce creuset
républicain bien mettre en péril la
république alors peut-être on n'a pas su
transmettre ses repères qu'on n'a pas su
transmettre ses valeurs
mais sur ce sujet de qui je ne crois pas
de kippa je ne crois pas à aller sur le
tigre sur ceux qui n'ont pas sûr qu'ils
pensent que s'ils ont besoin de parler
si par exemple est-ce que vous parlez de
l'enrichissement italien que votre
famille a pu apporter non mais je crois
que non maquette sensée escaut rural
mais c'était par les enfants quand je
vois ma famille vient de kabylie en
algérie je je je suis né au bon dans le
jeu s'en tiendrait désormais est ce
qu'on parle des enfants de france où des
gens venus d'ailleurs parce que ce n'est
pas la même chose
entendez bien les enfants nés en france
sont français
c'est parfois dans vos problèmes et
parfois meurent sont aussi dans le
propos voulait rejetée non oui sa
tension
souvent je vivais je vais vous prendre
un exemple qui m'a conduit à faire
adopter dans une large majorité à
l'assemblée nationale le fait que
désormais dans toutes les classes de
toutes les écoles de la république
seront apposées à la fois le drapeau
français le drapeau européen ainsi que
les paroles de la marseillaise dans le
projet de loi sur l'école je sais pas si
monsieur mendes vous l'a voté je n'en
suis pas certain mais il ya eu il ya eu
de larges
il ya une large majorité pourquoi j'ai
porté cet amendement parce que après les
attentats qui ont frappé notre pays en
janvier 2015 contre charlie hebdo vous
en rappelez sans doute scellé laugerette
et moi je suis le délai d'attenté leur
président dont on parle c'est le
président hollande qui avait demandé
d'ailleurs dans un beau moment d'unité
nationale que dans toutes les écoles
on observe une minute de silence est
malheureusement qu est ce qu on a
constaté que dans des mini
le cas sallaumines aurait mille
étudiants enfin vous êtes et un stadier
comme ceux ci sont l'inde et vous faites
encore là et me remit n'aurait pas le
même mais regardez regardez tout ce qui
brille sur ce qui s'était passé dans les
experts
au lieu de mai 2010 il ya eu quelques
bricoles des messages est posée s'il
vous plaît quand je reviendrai pas des
mesures d'école jeudi des milliers
d'enfants et même il y en aurait eu
qu'une dizaine ce serait une dizaine de
trop qui ont refusé d'observer sept
minutes les millions qu'ils ont ils été
et ils sont français
donc la question qui se pose c'est
comment des jeunes français ne les
pousse pas les valeurs de la république
on se retrouve alors de manas bleus sont
plus souvent même à des valeurs ou à des
règles religieuses donc c'est ce que je
refuse c'est ce modèle que je refuse et
aujourd'hui nous faut plus il nous faut
plus de la limite est de répondre et je
dis que depuis deux saisons je puis
depuis deux ans d'ailleurs manuel valls
que vous connaissez bien a eu toujours
un sens social très très clair sur ces
questions très partant des sofas le même
courage aujourd'hui on est bien c'est
dangereux si vous voulez là dessus il ya
pas de même eu le courage on ne ment pas
et les pansements 6-2 le montre sur
chaque projet de loi que nous montre
mais lui c'est votre point de vue
monsieur shakeel position sera jamais
d'accord c'est même un peu aussi grâce à
vous je me suis lancé à aborder celle
avantage c'est qu'on respecte la
diversité chez nous on ne vote pas comme
un seul homme au delà de ça c'est un peu
aussi grâce à vous à la fin et les
propos que vous avez tenus pendant des
années je me suis engagé en politique
donc je vais peut-être vous pour vous
remercier aujourd'hui c'est un peu grâce
à vous et nicolas sarkoz à l'époque que
moi j'ai atterri en politique parce que
tous ces propos là me disent que c'est
pas la france donc moi je leur ai lourde
et je rêve non c'est pas lourd est
réputé et en imposant au large et on est
quelques-uns c'est vrai en effet mais
sous la laïcité j'avais pas qu'on peut
parler de plus de laïcité on pas faire
mieux que la laïcité actuelle c'est dire
qu'on respecte toutes les religions et
on ne s'ingère pas dedans là vous parlez
de moi justement patronat et ceux qui
n'ont pas de religion c'est la liberté
de croire ou de ne pas croire ça c'est
la base de la loi de 1905
je travaille aussi sur le sujet je pense
vous avez fait un long travail sur le
sujet vous parler d'identité nationale
vous avez beaucoup parlé sur l'islam
pendant des années il ya peut-être des
problèmes en islam et n'est pas national
il est international la problématique
sur l'islam et il faut accepter de dire
que la problématique de l'islam à se
réglera pas en ce sens si je ne faisais
pas de garde fou contre l'islam mais
attendez faut pas tout confondre
je confonds pas du tout je parle d'un
islam en général et on parle bien d
islam en france et par valise un
allemand l'islamiste convient
aujourd'hui gay est aujourd'hui plus en
plus de chercheurs le montre du moins ce
qu'on appelle nous l'islamisme mais le
ces personnes qui sont dans un combat
qui se servent de la religion pour mener
des combats terroristes comme d'autres
qui sont dans une forme de radicalité
politique sont sur le même terreau
fertile ça veut dire qu'il ya un
problème en france
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une crise
d'appartenance collective de personnes
qui se retrouvent plus dans la
communauté nationale mais en partie
parce que des politiques et des
personnes les ont exclus par des
discours presque à la limite de la haine
des personnes qui leur ont dit que deux
façons vous voulez d'un quartier
populaire
vous ne comprenez pas vous n'êtes pas
dans la france parce que dans ses
attendus
j'ai pas tant de haine
non les prédicateurs et leur domaine
soyons juste honnête de seconde les
prédicats d'ailleurs vous dormez refusé
d comme dans tous les domaines dans tous
les domaines n'importe quel prédicateur
qui soit sur la religion ou autre se
sert de la misère sociale ou la misère
intellectuelle d'une personne qu'elle en
face d'elle pour s'en servir comme ça
toujours été le cas sont plus parlées
liens ou de toutes les autres et cela
qu'il faut combattre mais c'est le
bonheur petit bien non la raison on
parle souvent des images nouvelles
pressions sur fernand est même considéré
comme dangereux qui tire une certaine
presse aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
statut d' imam n'importe qui peut dire
je suis imam dans ma mosquée et ce n'est
pas une vraie mosquée parce qu'il ya pas
de l'urée quelle détermination pour
répondre au combat
si on a travaillé dessus rapporté deux
ans en sorte que certaines associations
et sa part fait de sa taille reste on
veut pas possible il faut les suivre
parce que c'est pas nous qui avons
frotte s'y colle alors que le débat sur
l'identité nationale 1 sur l'islam de
france fracture et les français ceux qui
ont commis des attentats depuis 2012
date où l'heure 2015 c'est encore
fracture c'est quand vous n'êtes pas
certain que de maintenance et non c'est
pas vrai la traction et la non c'est pas
le cvo discours de ton commis des
attentats n'ont pas fracturé la france
merci de la boîte ont réussi de ce brave
yeux qu'ils ont fait rouler son rally de
soirée vous l'avez dit ce soir
en tout ces gens là prennent la médaille
heures et de l'étranger c'est maintenant
ce que vous avez dit
ils ont fracturé par terriblement
nationale aujourd'hui même et vous le
savez mais non il est honteux c'est vous
ne laissez pas la gêne et moi j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont commis des
attentats n'ont pas rassuré la france
une partie de la france mais vous êtes à
tuer bien parti dans les coins se
reconnaît pas dans les propos avant même
les musulmans ne se reconnaissent pas
dans les attentats extrêmement dangereux
l'intérieur se connaissent il le
souligner il reste une minute trente
pour être parfaitement car passionnant
d'un monsieur mendes d'un côté nicolas
sarkozy de l'autre les terroristes et la
question est de savoir qui a fracturé
alors non mais votre réponse par
ailleurs être claque tracts ans mais les
attentats
les attentats ont fracturé la france
c'est normal on peut pas dire que ça va
passer mais ils ont aussi créé une unité
nationale après les attentats chose qui
n'est qu'ils avaient on a vu du beau
linge qu'ils étaient positifs non mais
où l'attendent les sénateurs si vous
voulez pas m'écouter
ils ont fracturé maison créée knees et
la galce mais les propos tenus par les
politiques fracture au quotidien des
français or les politiques aux côtés des
terroristes et noir et parce que je pars
hayes alors lancez-vous débats agités
marqués aura le mot de la fin parce que
moi je n'en ai pas une victime directe
du 13 novembre
donc moi je pourrais en parler des
oreilles vous sourire mais je crois que
c'est pas ça tu j'ai ouïe moi j'essaie
de tout à l'heure d'avoir un débat sur
ce qui fait la france qui fait france ce
qui fait que nous sommes tous des
enfants de france est très vite et c'est
le problème de vos deux parties tout le
monde est parti sur l'islam sur les
islamistes je dis pas que ça n'existe
pas je vous dis que essayer aujourd'hui
de rassembler les français et donc c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut plutôt
être sur la république ce qui nous
rassemble sans exclure voilà ce message
que je pourrais faire passer et donc je
pense encore une fois que pour cela
monsieur ciotti il dans ce cas cela
n'est pas bon et mendes quand le prix
implique a essayé de mettre aussi
l'identité ans son grand débat c'est
aussi une faute politique mais voilà
c'est terminé c'est terminé c'était
dedans c'était d'emmener des si vous
voulez
juste un mot ce qu'on s'arrête là quand
même des ce monsieur mais dès ce soir a
révélé
malheureusement son vrai visage et qui
est suffisamment on va pas ralentir l'an
dernier polémique vous est expliqué dans
votre sujet plaisir merci beaucoup merci
à ces deux d'avoir accepté de venir
débattre sur le parc d'auditions
publiques n'ont pas d'histoire ce soir
avec eric ciotti maintenant c'est la
troisième partie de l'émission avec nos
deux consoeurs des chaînes
parlementaires et le font leur entrée
[Musique]
brigitte boucher bonsoir rial manche et
bonsoir à vous une question si vous êtes
d'accord d'une internautes du figaro
pour vous sur le figaro life une
question innich demande est-ce que vous
accepteriez est-ce que vous appelleriez
à nouveau c'est pas nouveau d'ailleurs à
voter macron au second tour de la
présidentielle en 2022 contre marine le
pen
si la situation de 2017 recommence voilà
la question que faites vous à moi
personnellement je me suis abstenu au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
je les dis je le revendique
je me refuse aujourd'hui dans à ce choix
binaire parce que je sois binaire il me
paraît dangereux pour pour notre pays et
ils sont aujourd'hui d'envisager ce
choix déjà mais lorsque vous avez été
exposé à ce choix
vous avez refusé je me suis abstenu au
second tour l'abstention ça fait pas
monter le rassemblement national je me
suis abstenu au second tour vous poser
une question je vous dis ce que j'ai
fait je pense pas que ça fasse monter le
front national puisque c'est pas une
voix pour le front national
bien sûr mais voulait renvoyer macron
marine le pen majeau je crois qu'ils ont
un duo un peu un peu sinistre
aujourd'hui qui leur convient à tous les
deux et c'est dangereux pour notre pays
notre démocratie parce que d'un côté
s'entretient l'immobilisme puisque
finalement il n'y a aucun courage
politique dans la dans les mesures que
met en oeuvre ce gouvernement puisque
sans sa seule garantie de survie c'est
de dire c'est moi ou le chaos c'est
finalement les deux il n'y a pas un
candidat éliminé reste et youri terme
ans pour on reste dans cet immobilisme
ou c'est le front national voilà
regardez vite elle est là dans la
réalité ce duel en 2022 ou tout l'enjeu
pour les républicains c'est d'éviter
bien
ce duel nous d'autres lignes l et elle
est claire nous voulons proposer une
alternative responsable crédible
courageuse avec un vrai programme de
redressement économique pour faire
baisser les impôts après avoir fait
baisser les dépenses publiques de
réduire les déficits et un programme qui
crée enfin des emplois dans notre pays
on a des très loin aujourd'hui on est
dans l'agitation sur des sujets qui est
au nom absolument rien de concret au
plan économique se dégrade au plan de la
sécurité des français ça se dégrade au
plan des flux migratoires ça se dégrade
et on voit bien que il y a un lien
direct dans cette montée également on
l'évoqué dans le débat précédent de
cette montée aussi du communautarisme
donc les vrais sujets qui sont au coeur
des préoccupations des français ne
trouvent pas aujourd'hui de réponses
concrètes vous avez du talent dans
l'artifice entraîner dans la pluie donc
là que vous leur proposez c'est tout
l'enjeu pour nous c'est tout l'enjeu
pour nous de casser un peu ce système
verrouillé ou personne finalement
n'arrivent à s'immiscer parce que il y a
eu ce il y à cette réduction du débat
politique
puisqu'on est revenu sur la droite il
n'y est pas parvenu et j'en conviens
mais c'est tout l'enjeu pour nous un
petit mot sur ce que vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure une petite précision que
vous l'avez dit mais sans être très
clair qu' il ya un certain nombre de
personnes en interne dans votre parti
qui aurait saboté entre guillemets la
campagne entre les qui serait
responsable de cette défaite vous visez
qui particulière au jeu
j'ai pas parlé de la campagne des
élections européennes j'ai parlé de ce
qui a suivi qu'ils avaient les élections
elle la nomination d'edouard philippe de
monsieur darmanin de monsieur le maire
n'avait d'autre objectif que sa beauté
la droite
bien entendu c'est pour cela qu'ils sont
là c'est pour cela qu'ils ont été
choisis au départ pour fragmenter notre
famille politique se sont ralliés après
monsieur raffarin notamment sa vis tous
ceux qui qui ont donné du crédit à la
majorité actuelle contre leur famille
police tous ceux qui n'ont pas choisi en
tout cas comme christian estrosi ça vise
tout ce qui est quelque part ont
fragilisé notre notre famille politique
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaite c'est que
nous nous rassemblions qu'il y ait une
unité je pense en particulier à xavier
bertrand qui a quitté notre famille
politique je pense qu'il faut il faut
que le vainqueur laurent wauquiez est un
dialogue avec lui laurent wauquiez nous
l'a dit au bureau politique il aura un
dialogue avec les personnalités de notre
famille politique il a dit également
qu'il aurait un dialogue à l'extérieur
de notre famille politique est bien dans
cet extérieur je pense notamment aux
notions qu'il faut et qu'il y ait ce
dialogue avec ceux qui ceux qui sont
partis mais qui n'ont pas rejoint en
marche et c'est notamment le cas de
xavier bertrand qui étrille encore
capable qui est très critique par
rapport à en marche fait la différence
entre ceux qui sont aussi avec entre
ceux qui sont allés peut-être mais je
fais la différence entre ceux qui sont
partis parce que
ne ressentez pas peut-être les mêmes
dans un moment donné sur des sujets
particuliers la même approche et ceux
qui sont partis pour déplacer des postes
c'était que le mouvement va s'amplifier
aujourd'hui après le résultat des
européennes eric ciotti puisqu'on prête
l'intention évidemment notamment au
premier ministre et au chef de l'état de
poursuivre ce travail de refondation on
voit bien objectif de ca annuel macron
c'est c'est de faire disparaître la
droite républicaine
bon nous ferons tout pour l'empêcher de
réussir dans cette entreprise qu'il
n'ait d'entreprise qui peut être
dangereuse pour nous mais là n'est pas
l'essentiel mais qui j'en suis
profondément convaincu et dangereuse
pour la presse que ce sont vos anciens
amis qui sont les premiers à mettre en
oeuvre cet objectif edouard philippe a
fait campagne uniquement quasiment
uniquement dans des villes de droite
pour rallier à lui votre par hasard ce
n'est pas par hasard
voilà il est là avec une mission
président de la république lui a pas
donné la mission de redresser le pays
il lui a donné la mission de fragmenter
la droite est ici applique avec un
certain zèle quand le premier ministre
parle de droite trocadéro est ce qui
vous fait particulièrement mal et ce qui
est ce qui touche là où ça fait mal et
ce qu'ils visent juste finalement je ne
crois pas la droite qu trocadéro c'est
une droite qui assume ses convictions
c'est une droite qui restaient debout
dans l'adversité dans la tempête si
cette droite avait été un peu plus
nombreuses à très peu nous aurions été
au second tour et donc c'est pas moi qui
la fustigent rien ou geoffroy didier a
dit ce matin qu'il fallait faire une
sorte d'app jeunes armento sur les
valeurs sociétales
il parle de libérer mais il ya aussi la
pma il ya aussi la fin de vie est ce que
vous êtes vraiment en phase avec la
société française sur toutes ces
questions
c'est une île a eu raison d'ouvrir ce
débat et je partage je partage son
analyse il faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus
en phase sur sur ces questions qu'on
mesure les évolutions sociétales
peut-être même qu'on les anticipe plutôt
qu'on donne l'impression de de rester
figé sur sur sur un certain modèle donc
c'est
naturellement là dessus il faut que
connaît cette réflexion et qu'elle soit
qu'elles soient sans tabou tout cas moi
personnellement je me retrouve dans
cette cette volonté aussi de de
comprendre ses aspirations ses
évolutions nouvelle on va parler une
révolution culturelle un peu pour
certains assez voyez tout à l'heure on
évoquer le mon attachement une certaine
culture à une certaine identité à des
rats side mais ses racines elles sont
aussi la garantie d'un avenir parce que
un arbre sans racines c'est un arbre
c'est un arbre mort donc il faut aussi
que pour qu'on progresse pour qu'on se
tourne vers les évolutions comprennent
le défi de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on écoute les aspirations sociétal
ont sonné aussi cette histoire et cette
culture connaît en partage mais il faut
les deux on peut pas rester que sur un
côté auriol on va parler de naissains
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure je
suis persuadé que les choses se
régleront au sein de ma propre famille
politique comment est-ce que vous n'êtes
prêt à ne pas aller dans cette bataille
des municipales pour éviter un duel
fratricide avec les sons estrosi écouter
aujourd'hui je suis pas engagée dans ce
deal et demain je suis député nice et
toutes mes prises de position sur nice
se sont inscrits dans le strict respect
du mandat que m'ont confié les électeurs
niçois par trois fois au coeur de la
ville de nice dans le le coeur de l'anis
historique dans le vieux nice dans le
quartier du port j'ai défendu j'ai pris
des engagements notamment qu'il n'y ait
pas d'augmentation de la fiscalité
notamment que l'argent public soit géré
avec beaucoup de prudence parce qu'il y
avait jusqu'au bout de vêtements d'un
plus grand ailleurs votre engagement de
rendre les lecteurs sécurité un discours
de candidat sécurité demande à députés
ou pas ça est compatible avec moment
avec mon mandat de député jusqu à eybens
jusqu'en 2002 les municipales je m'y
emploie tous les jours voilà donc après
nous verrons bien comment là où je serai
le plus utile pour pour servir ma ville
c'est j'ai réfléchi c'est le genre se
lancer c'est le seul objectif qui
m'anime tout à l'heure vous disiez ça se
règlera dans notre famille politique ce
que je ce que disent en tout cas les les
analyses ou les sondages qui ont été
publiés c'est qu'il peut y avoir un
débat entre christian estrosi et moi
aujourd'hui qu'on oublie qu'on aime en
face à face est enfin sa face au coude à
coude
voilà face à face quand même parce que
il y à il y a eu des attitudes
différentes ça soit sur un plan
politique
j'ai gardé une certaine une certaine
ligne sur une sur des modèles de gestion
sur une approche tout simplement de la
vie publique est ce que vous vous
déterminerez sur cette candidature
éventuelle je me déterminerai dans
quelques semaines mais le belge est née
quand est-ce que vous la chose je le dis
ça je vous laisse la responsabilité de
cette annonce mais moi je le ferai avec
responsabilité pour servir ma ville et
pour en pensant d'abord on y soit 0,12 à
merveille j'ai toujours envie de servir
ma ville bien sûr lui donner le meilleur
j'y suis né
je suis très fier d'en être l'élu de
l'avoir servi à la tête du département
des alpes-maritimes aussi c'est une
ville merveilleuse qui a des atouts qui
à l'histoire vaut qu'il qui a des
difficultés aussi question autrement
eric ciotti vous êtes président de la
commission nationale des investitures
pour les républicains ce que vous
pourrez donner investiture la question
est posée lorsque viendra la situation
de l'église
je pense que je ne présiderai pas ce
jour là en tout cas cette séance donc en
quoi est ce que vous pensez pas que la
république en marge pourrait vous jouer
un tour et décidé de ne pas mettre deux
candidats si toutefois c'était christian
estrosi et en mettent si c'était vous
l'histoire de de vous faire un
croche-patte par exemple
rien n'est exclu dans les grosses pattes
de la république en marche mais en tout
cas moi je ne me réfère pas aux
attitudes de la république en marge
d'une affaire à mes convictions qui
n'ont pas changé et encore aujourd'hui
voilà on a subi deux défaites de hyères
forte lourde mais moi je me battrai
toujours pour ma conviction parce que je
considère qu'elles sont bonnes pour le
pays qu'elles sont bonnes pour ma ville
en tous les cas christian estrosi eux et
qui donc vous êtes au coude à coude et
demain face à face donc vous a peut-être
joué un tour là parce qu'on l'avait
entendu on l'avait vu flirter avec
emmanuel macron 1 depuis l'élection du
chef de l'état et là paf il a appelé à
voter françois xavier bellamy jeunes
alors est ce que ça leur ne le
réinstalle pas comme candidat légitime
de votre parti je m'en réjouis
j'espère que ça sera une ligne désormais
durable un bon vous allez entrer dans un
développement durable dans cette aide
vous pensez que le font certains
retraits environnement que vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir des retours de
balancer successifs pour ne pas que
c'est ailleurs monsieur estrosi mais
d'autres maires de grandes villes ça
vient l heure rien n'est jamais à
exclure politique
ça a été un bon verre quand même
christian estrosi c'est un bon ben ça
fait 10 ans arrivé il y à il ya des
réalisations positives naturellement et
je les ai je les ai souligné il ya des
forces et des faiblesses
les réalisations positives elle trouve
une contrepartie négatives dans un
endettement qui a conduit à une
augmentation lourde de la fiscalité
voilà donc dans la vie publique il faut
toujours trouver un équilibre parce que
quand on gère quand on réalise on ne le
fait pas avec son argent on le fait avec
l'argent du contribuable qui est
lourdement sollicités donc toute
réalisation doit aussi être apprécié à
la façon dont elle est financée nice
s'est beaucoup endetté
nice a des impôts qui ont beaucoup
augmenté
donc il y a cette balance à trouver
après il ya eu des bonnes réalisations
je les ai soutenus je pense notamment
aux tramways ou au stade en tant que
président du département puisque le
département a apporté une aide très
conséquente sur ces deux projets c'est
presque 100 millions d'euros à la fois
sur le les lignes de tramway et sur le
stade pour la ville de nice très bien
donc on n'aura pas votre déclaration
comme des natures ce soir on va donc
changer de sujet maintenant orient oui
on va parler d'un sujet d'actualité
quatre français condamné à mort par un
tribunal de bagdad pour appartenance à
l'organisation état islamique est ce que
la france doit empêcher que cette
condamnation à mort cette peine de mort
soit effective la france ses
ressortissants français sont jugés en
irak parce qu'ils ont commis doukha et
ils ont été condamnés pour cela ils ont
commis des crimes abominables avec une
situation terrifiante où la vie humaine
a été considéré comme totalement
secondaire où on a décapité des gens où
on a joué au football avec
les têtes des personnes qui ont été
décapités ou un à martyriser des femmes
donc derrière il ya des horreurs ou le
terrifiant tout un a commandité des
attentats dans les personnes qui ont été
condamnées une est en lien avec berra
l'autre est en lien avec la famille
klein qui fait partie des commanditaires
de l'attentât du bataclan donc il ya
derrière tout ça c'est français moi je
considère que quelque part ils ne sont
plus français parce qu'ils ont trahi la
france
ils ont fait un choix de rentrer en
guerre contre notre pays sont joués
aujourd'hui jugée en irak
c'est la faire de l'irak donc il faut
que le jugement s'applique toujours pas
connaissance en mêlée pour moi il faut
que les gens s'impliquent sauf que
depuis 1980 on n'a pas la même justice
que l'irak est ce qu'on peut laisser
faire ça ou est ce qu'il ya de la
complicité de peine de mort sedan
serrières un vrai ça ne m'a pas échappé
mais ils sont jugés par riera complicité
peine de mort le quai d'orsay rappelle à
bagdad que la france est un pays qui a
aboli la peine de mort est ce que ce
genre de rappel de démarches officielles
par le canal diplomatique et justifier
ce ben je crois quand même savoir que
monsieur macron a souhaité qu'il soit
jugé en irak
donc il savait qu'il y ait accepté dès
peines est confiant on savait très bien
qu'elle était
le droit pénal qui s'applique à dire à
tous voilà très bien donc on ne peut pas
là aussi avoir un espèce de discours en
même temps parce que vous êtes confiant
dans les assurances réitérées par le
ministère de la justice
quant à la libération d'anciens
terroristes qui vont sortir des prisons
françaises ans je suis je suis
absolument pas confiance je suis même au
contraire très très inquiet il y a en
prison aujourd'hui environ 500 personnes
qui sont impliquées ou condamnées dans
des affaires terroristes
il y en a plus d'un millier qui sont
radicalisées qui sont des détenus ou des
prévenus de droit commun beaucoup vont
sortir dans les semaines et dans l'est
dans les mois qui viennent plusieurs
plusieurs centaines pas confiance et
c'est une écriture positif mais pas
suffisamment et trois mois j'avais prôné
avec avec certains de mes collègues à
l'assemblée donc dont guillaume là le
député guillaume larrivé qu'on mette en
place un dispositif de rétention de
sûreté et qui est identique à celui qui
avait été mis en place par nicolas
sarkozy à l'égard des grands criminels
sexuels des des criminels pédophiles
notamment pour qu'après la peine quand
la peine est terminée et bien la société
sache protéger qui peut dire il faut
qu'ils aient une évaluation très précise
que ces personnes qui vont sortir de
prison ne représente pas un danger pour
la société
on a aujourd'hui dans des établissements
des personnes qui sont frappés de
troubles psychiatriques
elles vivent en milieu fermé parce
qu'elle représente une menace pour la
société est bien la rétention de sûreté
c'est le même dispositif
la peine a été purgée mais la société
doit pouvoir se protéger on nous refuse
cette protection
je pense que c'est dangereux vous faites
confiance à christophe castaner pour
assurer la sécurité en france ô il avait
beaucoup critiqué bien sûr dans sa
gestion de la crise
oh non il a mis en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et ce n'est toujours
pas réglée à apporter des réponses à
cette montée ils veulent que toute cette
affaire montée de la violence moi ce que
je vois aujourd'hui c'est un immense
malaise chez les policiers il ya eu 31
suicides depuis le début de l'année et
il y à une situation où on n'a
absolument pas régler les problématiques
qui se posent à nos forces de l'ordre
moyens humains moyens budgétaires moyens
matériels l'état régalien en 50 ans et
j'en fais pas le procès à christophe
castaner ni même à ce gouvernement
on peut partager collectivement cette
responsabilité parce qu'elle est plus
ancienne mais en 50 ans l'état régalien
c'est-à-dire ce pourquoi il fait l'état
la sécurité la justice leur moyens ont
été divisés par deux donc j'ai annuel
macron augmente les effectifs des
policiers des gendarmes quand vous les
avez baissé sur le quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy pas à la hauteur des nouvelles
menaces qui sont apparues donc je
défendrai un texte à l'assemblée
nationale le 20 juin prochain une
proposition de loi de programmation qui
sera débattue dans la semaine
d'initiative des républicains qui
permettra justement sur 50 de donner des
moyens considérables supplémentaires 15
milliards de rattraper vos yeux quinze
mille effectifs de plus faire en sorte
qu'on réhabilite les commissariats qu'on
renouvelle les véhicules
et puis surtout qu'on sanctionne aussi
par des peines plancher ce qui porte
atteinte à l'uniforme à nos policiers à
nogent dano pompiers aussi parce qu'il
faut protéger ce qui nous protège de ce
texte sont rasées double objectif plus
de moyens plus de protection suivra ces
débats merci beaucoup eric ciotti
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui merci
madame
merci à tous on se retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]